[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه يقول ان العمليه رد
على اطلاق الصواريخ وحماس تصف القصف
بامتداد للحرب المفتوحه على الفلسطينيين
والاحتلال يواصل حملات الاعتقال في الضفه
الغربيه
[موسيقى]
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني يقول ان
المبررات المقدمه
لا تستند الى الموضوعيه مشيرا الى النفاق
في الهجمات التي تستهدف بلاده وتتجاهل كل
الانجازات التي حققتها ويعرب على اعتقاده
ان هناك من لا يقبل ان يستضيف بلد صغير من
الشرق الاوسط وينظم حدثا كونيا مثل بطوله
كاس العالم حزب انصاف يتهم الحكومه
الباكستانيه بتدبير محاوله اغتيال رئيس
الوزراء السابق عبر الخال ويتعهدوا
بالانتقام ويدعم ايديه تظاهر ضد ما وصفه
بالحكومه المستورده وانصار الحزب يواصلنا
مسيرتهم نحو اسلام اباد ويستعدون لتنظيم
وقفات احتجاجيه في مدن عده والحكومه ترفض
الاتهامات وتدعو الحسبه لمراجعه ترتيباته
الامنيه لحمايه الاحتجاجات عقب اسبوع واحد
من استحواذ على تويتر يسرح نحو نصف
العاملين في الشركه بحسب وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه موظفات تويتر يرفعون قضائيه
جماعيه ضد الشركه بتهمه انتهاك القانون
الفيدرالي وعدم اختارهم بالتسريح الجماعي
قبل 60 يوما الى اللقاء